[موسيقى]
هناك من بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
التومان الايراني على حافه الانهيار
والنظام يلتف على عجزه في كبح الاحتجاجات
بالاعدامات وشرطه الاخلاق
رسائل بوتينسكي الحرب حتى النصر روسيا
تستهدف مصانع المصيرات في دنيتك وكيب
تنشرها مارس في لوجان
انجريكا الصندوق النقد الدوليه تنبا بسنه
صعبه على الجيوب
واقتصاد العالم سيتلقى ايضا ضربه من الصين
بسبب كورونا واوروبا تخفق في وضع اليه
مشتركه لقيود السفر
[موسيقى]
كل عام وانتم بالف خير مشاهدينا الكرام
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه في ايران يسعى
النظامه للالتفاف على عجزه في كبح
الاحتجاجات المستمره في البلاد فاخرج من
جديد حبال المشانق واصدر اليوم حكما
باعدام احد المتظاهرين المعتقلين في
محافظه مادران شمال طهران بالتزامن افاد
التقارير بنشر السلطات الايرانيه شرطه
الاخلاق في شوارع البلاد وضوابط الحجاب
الالزاميه بحسب وكاله انباء فارس
في الشرطه الايرانيه عوده الرسائل النصيه
التي تتعلق بالزاميه الحجاب لاصحاب
السيارات في جميع انحاء البلاد وقالت
الوكاله انا رسائل نصيه ترسل لتذكره اصحاب
السيارات التي يتم فيها خلع الحجاب وتشير
تقارير على مواقع التواصل الى عوده شرطه
الاخلاق في شوارع طهران التي كان نائب
العام
قناه شاطها
وتاتي عوده انتشار شرطه الاخلاق في ظل
الاستمرار الاحتجاجات في انحاء البلاد
واستنتشرنا نمي المكثف من الشرطه
الايرانيه في بعض المناطق
[موسيقى]
هذا وافدت قناه ايران انترناشونال بتوتر
الاوضاع بمدينه سميرم في محافظه اصفهان
وسط البلاد بعد مقتل عنصر من الحرس الثوري
في المدينه وذكرت القناه وان قوه الامن
الايرانيه هاجمت من الى احد ضحايا
الاحتجاجات في سمر واعتقلت بعض اقاربه
[موسيقى]
وعلى واقع حمله في قمع النظام في الداخل
نشدت الاستخبارات الداخليه الالمانيه ذوي
الاصول الايرانيه المعارضين الى توخي
الحذر على رغبتهم في السفر الى ايران
واكدت الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان علي ذوي
الاصول الايرانيه المعارضين توقع عواقب
وخيمه وقال رئيس الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان
المشاركين في تظاهرات التضامن مع ايران
السابقه التقطت صورا ومقاطع فيديو لبعضهم
ونشروها على مواقع التواصل ما سهل على
الاجهزه الايرانيه تحديده هوياتهم
[موسيقى]
ومع حجب الانترنت من قبل النظام الايراني
تكبدت شركات الاتصالات في ايران خسائر
ماليه ضخمه وكاله انباء الطلبه الايرانيه
كشفت عن ان خمسه شركه كبرى للاتصالات
والانتاجات وصلت الى حافه الافلاس منذ
الشهر الاول للاحتجاجات الاخيره بحسب خطاب
ارسلته شركه مبينه الى هيئه الاتصالات
الرسميه فقد تضررت بنحو عشره مليارات
تومان اي ما يعادل 25% من دخلها فيما خسرت
شركه ايران سيل 800 مليار توما
ازمه اخرى تشهدها ايران فيها عملتها على
حافه الانهيار كذلك وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه
افادت بان تغيير رئيس البنك المركزي
الايراني لا يعد كافيا لحل الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تعاني منها البلاد هي مام
مع التضخم الذي يرافق قيمه التومان
الايراني منذ اكثر من شهرين
تسلك العمله الايرانيه مسار انحراريا سبق
لليرتين السوريه واللبنانيه عند خالتها في
نفقه
ورغم اقاله رئيس البنك المركزي الايراني
صالح عيادي وتعيين محمد رضا فرزين بدلا
منه لا يبدو كبح تدهور العمله الايرانيه
في متناول السلطات الايرانيه
في وقت فقد فيه التومان الايراني نحو ربع
قيمته في شهرين فقط ما جعل هذا التغيير لا
يعد حلا كافيا وفقا لخبراء اقتصاديين
صحيفه ارمان نيللي الاصلاحيه الايرانيه
ذكرت انه من الخطا انتظار معجزه يقودها
رئيس البنك المركزي الجديد بالاضافه الى
انه لا جدوى من هذه التغييرات ما دامت
السياسه العامه للنظام الايراني غير قابله
لتعديل مسارها والعلاقات بين ايران ودول
العالم شبه منقطعه جراء العزله الدوليه
والعقوبات المفروضه على طهران بسبب قمعها
احتجاجات
يضاف اليها التورط الايراني في تسليح
روسيا بالطائرات المسيره التي تستهدف
منشات المدنيه الاوكرانيه بينها البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه ما تسبب ايضا لايران
بخساره الموقف الاوروبي الوسطي وجنوحه
اكثر نحو الموقف الامريكي وبالتالي عقوبات
اوروبيه بعد الامريكيه التضخم ايضا مشكله
كبيره في ايران على ضوء الارقام القياسيه
التي يسجلها
تضخم يترافق مع انخفاض في قيمه التمان من
نحو
330,000 الى
430,000, مقابل الدولار الامريكي
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه كارثه انسانيه
تهدد افغانستان والسبب قيوده طالبان ضد
المراه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اوكرانيا اجهضت
امنيته حلول السلام مع بدايه
في مناطق مختلفه في اوكرانيا وتحديدا
العاصمه التي توقفت فيها امدادات الطاقه
الروسيه وايضا مدينه تميكو لايف جنوب
البلاد ما تسبب في دمار
[موسيقى]
وتعليقا على الهجمات الاخيره قال الجيش
الروسي من الضربات التي نفذت على مدن
اوكرانيه عده بينها كيف ليله راس السنه
استهدفت منشات لصناعه السيارات بهدف احباط
هجمات
مباريات مباريات
القوات الروسيه ضربه جويه باسلحه عاليه
الدقه على مرافق صناعيه اوكرانيه تستعمل
في تصنيع وتطوير الطائرات مسيره الهجوميه
والتي تستخدم ضد روسيا كما قامت قوتنا
باستهداف مرافق تخزين الطائرات المسيره
وتعطيل خطتك كيف لتنفيذ الهجمات على روسيا
ومن الواضح ان موسكو بصدر توجيه العمليه
العسكريه نحو مسار جديد من خلال تكثيف
الهجمات في اكثر من منطقه وهو ما اكد عليه
ايضا رئيس الروسي العظيم في خطاب بمناسبه
العام الجديد مشيرا الى ان الحرب ستواصل
هو جاي ما يقراش دنيا
الاعزاء حمل عام 2022 عدد من القرارات
الضروريه الصعبه وذلك بهدف اكتساب السياده
الكامله لروسيا وحده مجتمعه
من اجله من خلال حمايه شعبنا في اراضينا
التاريخيه في المناطق الجديده الروسيه
من الغربه
ننتصر فقط
وتبحث القوه الروسيه عن تحقيق ما كسب
اضافيه في الشرق الاوكراني بعد تكبيرها
لخسائر في الجنوب وتحديدا في خرسون التي
استعادت كيف سيطره عليها
على الجانب الاخر القوات الاوكرانيه شنت
هجمات هي الاخرى على بعض الاهداف الروسيه
وتحديدا في مقاطعه لوغانسك حيث نشرت في
ضواحيها صواريخ هاي مارس ويبدو بان العام
الجديد لا يشهد على المدى المنظور توقفا
للمعارك حيث اكد رئيس الاوكرانيينزلينسكي
ان هذا العام سيكون عاما مصر في الحرب ضد
روسيا مشدده على ان قوه بلاده ستواصل
القتال حتى استعاده السيطره على كافه
الاراضي الاكرانيا
من جانبها اذنه سفيره الامريكيه تولد
اوكرانيا الاستهدافات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
قائله في تغريده لها ان الهجوم الروسيه
على اوكرانيا في الساعه الاولى من العام
الجديد عمل جبان مضيفه الان الولايات
المتحده واثقه تماما من انتصار اوكرانيا
في حربها خلال عام 2023
مع المستشاره في البرلمان الاوكرانيه من
شوك سيده ميلا اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه من العربيه كنت اود ان اقول لك
نتمنى لك عاما سعيدا ولاوكرانيين كذلك
ولكن يبدو ان المعارك لم تتوقف حتى في
ليله راس السنه لماذا
تحياتنا
ونتمنى لكم سنه سعيده
لكن
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا ضخمه جدا
وهي تزداد
فراشه همم
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
همم
فانا في
ثياب
والمطاعم والمحلات
ما زال تعمل
وا علينا العشيه راس السنه
اصبح يكرهه ارض الروس اكثر من اي وقت سبق
بسبب هذه الهامات
فالدفاعات الاوكرانيه
فاعله
لكن للاسف هناك اربع قتلى
ضخم في اوكرانيا
الدفاع الاوكرانيه طيب
هذا كما ذكرته هذا يوم عن بدايه
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الجديده الروسيه في
الحرب في اوكرانيا مع بدايه العام الجديد
يعني مع اول ليله في العام الجديد 2023 ما
عساها تكون هذه الاستراتيجيه هناك تحليلات
تذهب على انه ستكون حرب اوسع نطاقه تشارك
فيها ربما بلا روسيا الى جانب روسيا
في المعسكر الغربي مع اوكرانيا كذلك همم
ما هي الاستراتيجيه الجديده لهذه الحرب في
الاتحاد الروسي هم يغيرون اهداف
هذه
عملياتهم الخاصه
في البدايه
قالوا انهم الذي يستهدفوا
المناطق المدنيه او المدنيين لكن الان هم
يستهدفون كل شيء مدني
في المستشفيات يعني
غيروا غيروا كل ما قالوا في البدايه انهم
لم يفعله هو الان يفعلونه هذه تغييرات
كبيره همم نحن لدينا خشيه وقلق بان
مديحه
تشارك بالحرب لانهم كان دوله مشتركه
وكانهم تحالف وربما
على بلاروس
كان هناك مظاهرات
وايضا
التورك
بالتالي
ستكون هناك ثوره جديده بين فئه شعبه
وبالتالي همم
اوكرانيا بل ستكون مشكله لداخل بلا روسيا
من ناحيه الشعب وهذا سيعود كبير
وهمم اوكرا يمكن ان تكون الجزء من قوات
مشتركه همم
مجموعه من الدول
والشركه وقد التقوا مؤخرا
وبنيتالي بالنسبه لي ارى
انه لا يوجد اي احد لهم مصلحه همم
زياده التصعيد لانه سيزيد
من الاخطار
على كل الاطراف
ايضا بان ان روسيا يمكن ان تستخدم سلاح
النوويه
الولايات المتحده لديها سلاح
وهذا هذه المخاطره كبيره
فظيعه
ممكن بالنسبه لهم يستخدموا هذا سلاح
التكتيكيكي
عمليات سيكون لديهم 12 ساعه
وعندها ربما ستقوم الولايات المتحده ونيته
بدر السباقيه على روسيا همم في حال فكروا
باستخدام السلاح النوويه وبالتالي
اوكرانيا
وقواتها وتاهبها العسكري لحمايه اراضيها
شكرا جزيلا لك همم
انت مستشار في البرلمان الاوكراني كنت
معنا من كينيا
[موسيقى]
العام الجديد لا يبدو مبشرا ايضا بالنسبه
للاقتصاد العالمي الذي يصير نحو الركود
التحذير جاء من صندوق النقد الدولي الذي
توقع ان يشهد الاقتصاد العالمي وركودا في
الربع الثالث من عام 2013
[موسيقى]
توقعات صندوق النقد الدولي هذه تعزز
التقارير التي صدرت ايام قبل نهايه العام
المنصرم والتي توقعت ركودا في العام
الجديد وكان مركز ابحث لي اقتصاد والاعمال
البريطانيه قد توقع اي واجهه الاقتصاد
العالمي ركودا في 2023 بسبب ارتفاع تكاليف
الاقتراض التي تم اللجوء اليها لمواجهه
التضخم
[موسيقى]
اعاده تعصين لتشغل العلم مره اخرى باخبار
كورونا او بالاحرار عدد كورونا تقلق
العالم ما بعد تعليق سياسه صفر كوميديه
شهدت الصين ارتفاع واضحا في اعداد
الاصابات واثار تكدس المصابين في
المستشفيات الزهره من عوده سيناريو عام
[موسيقى]
والقلق بدا يتسرب خارج حدود الصين ويصل
هذه المره الى مجموعه من الدول التي بادرت
بسرعه الى اتخاذ اجراءات الاعتراضيه في
وجه القادمين من الصين وتزايد عدد الدول
التي تفرض قيود على القادمين من الصين
يرتفع الى 12 بلدا بعد انضمت استراليا الى
كل من الولايات المتحده وكندا واليابان
وبعض الدول الاوروبيه من بينها فرنسا التي
حثت دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه الاخرى على
اجراء اختبارات للمسافرين القادمين من
الصين وكان المغرب اعلن عن حضر دخول
المسافرين القادمين من الصين اعتبارا من
الثالث من يناير لتجنب موجه جديده من
العدوى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الارتفاع الاخير في عدد الاصابات يعود
بالاساس الى ظهور المتحولا جديد وهو ما
كانت كشفت عنه منظمه الصحه العالميه وتم
تصنيف المتحور على انه شديد العدوى
والانتشار كما انه سبب زياده حالات
الاصابات في الصين واوضح التقارير الطبيه
ان المتحوله الجديد يهاجم الجهاز التنفسي
بشكل اقل من غيره لكنه ينتشر بشكل كبير
واطلقت مجموعه من العلماء تحذيرات من
المتحور الجديد هذا الذي يعتبر اكثر شراسه
مقارنه بالمتحورات الاكثر انتشارا في
الوقت الحالي وذلك نقلا عن تقريرا صحيفه
ديل ميل البريطانيه
معنى منه مشجن خبير اللقاحات والاستاذ
بجامعه البروفيسور علي فطوم بروفيسور علي
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه كل عام وانت
بخير لا يبدو ان الاخبار مبشره يعني مع
بدايه هذا العام هل تعتقد ان هناك حاجه
لاغلاق السفر مره اخرى مع الصين كما بدات
تفعل بعض الدول
ما يحصل الان هو بالفعل عمليه انتشار
الفيروس ويذكرنا بما حدث في الدول الغربيه
في اواخر نوفمبر ان انتشار الام ميكرون
هائلا لمده شهر اثنين شهرين بينما في
الصين هناك سياسه همم سياسه السفر
الفايروس وبالتالي لم يتعرض قسم كبير من
الناس لهذا الفايروس ولذلك لم تكتسب
المناعه الجماعيه او المناعه القطيع في
الصين بينما اكتسبت في الدول الغربيه
الاخرى متاح لنا
انفتاح في شهر اربعه وخمسه والان
التحديثات قليله جدا بالنسبه للصين هنالك
مشكله كبيره ان ال- ال- عدد الانكشاف
للفيروس كان قليل جدا وبالتالي نحن في
حاله الانفتاح يظهر لدينا
فعاليه من الاصابات هذه النسبه على
الاصابات قد تؤدي في نهايه الامر الى ظهور
مناعه القطيع ان تصل من كلامك بروفيسور
انت ضد سياسه الاغلاق يعني انه من الافضل
ان تبقى الحدود مفتوحه وان نتعامل مع
مختلف المتحولات حتى نكتسب مناعه
من سلاله الاوميكرون وكل ما تفضلت فيه
وانت تعريف للاوميكرون انه يصيب الجهاز
التنفسي العلوي وبالتالي انتشار هذا
الفايروس سيكون يؤدي في نهايه الامر الى
مناعه القطيع الان قضيه التحديد السفر هي
قضيه مهمه لانه احنا تعودنا الان رجعنا
الى السفر بدون كما ماء وكل شيء منفتح
وبالتالي
عدد كبير من الناس الذي من الممكن يحمله
هذا الفيروس سيؤدي الى انتشاره في الاماكن
المغلقه وهذا طبعا شيء صعب انك تتحكم فيه
وبالتالي هذه التحديدات مهمه للسفر وليست
مهمه
للتمازج او الاتصال المباشر بين الدول ما
مدى خطوره هذا المتحول صحيح ان هناك
تقارير انه المتحول هذا المنتشر الان في
الصين ينتشر بشكل سريع جدا ولكنه غير خطير
ولكن في نفس الوقت كان هناك صور للناس
مقدسين في المستشفيات في الصين وبانه هناك
قد ايه اعداد فارقت الحياه بسبب هذا
المتحول همم ماذا نعرف عن مدى خطوره هذا
المتحول الجديد
يعني في المتحول لانكرون اللي ظهر في
نوفمبر 21 في جنوب افريقيا وانتشر بصوره
هائله واستولى طبعا على كل الدول العالم
المميز الذي يميز هذا الفيروس انه له انه
ضعيف ال ال ال ال ان يتكاثر في داخل
الرئتين هو فقط في الجهاز التنفسي العلوي
وطبعا الحالات المرضيه موجوده هي لندن
تنتهي ظلت هناك حالات مرضيه وبعض الناس
كبار في كبار السن والذين لديهم امراض
الاخرين سيمرضون سيدخلون الى المستشفى
ولكن عدد الوفيات اقل واصبح الان الان
استطعنا ان الموجود الان حوالي 70 الف
حاله يوميا في الولايات المتحده
ذكرت ان المتحول الجديد هذا يهاجم الجهاز
التنفسي العلوي ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ما هي
اعراضها احتقان في الحلق ما هي الاعراض
الخاصه بالمتحول الجديد اذا كيف نعرف انه
هذا هو الجديد
نعم تشبه الاعراض تشبه اعراض الكوبيد
الاساسيه الملاحظنا رجعنا للاساس كان
الكوبيد يدخل الى الجهاز التنفسي يتكاثر
لمده خمسه ايام ثم ينتقل الى الرئتين
وتبدا الحاله الصعبه والحالات المرضيه
والوفاء هذا الفيروس الاوبكرون يستطيع ان
يتكاثر بسرعه اكثر وان يصل الى نسبه عاليه
ولكنه عندما يصل الى الرئتين يفقد قدرته
او من بعض القدرات التي لديه للتكاثر في
داخل الرئتين ولذلك تطور الكوفيد المرض
الكوفت في داخل الرئتين يكون باسهل بكثير
من من الفيروس الاصلي ولذلك اكتشف اكتسب
هذا الفيروسته التكاثر بشكل سريع في
الجهاز التنفس العلوي مما يؤدي الى
الانتقال السريع الى الاخرين ولكن فقد
قدرته على ان يسبب المرض الصعب جدا الا في
الحالات التي هنالك شروطها واسباب معينه
لانكشاف هذه هؤ
اذا هذا الفايروس هو الاساس الذي سيعطينا
عمليه القناعه القطيع والتي اكتسبناها نحن
هنا في الولايات المتحده وفي الدول الاخرى
في ما بين شهر 11 وشهر 2 3 22 مما ادى انه
قد فتحنا على
قلنا كل
الاوراق
يجب ان تنكشف الصين انفتاح في الصين سيؤدي
الى انكشاف عدد الميكرون سيكون هنالك ثمن
ولكن هذا الثمن مقارنه في الزمن الذي كان
ممكن دفعه بالفيروس الاصليه قليل جدا
ومحتمل هو طبعا هنالك تقصيرات ولا يوجد
لديك بعض الادويه التي موجوده الان زي
الباكسوفيت تبع فايزر غير موجود في الصين
فش حدا بيحكي فيهم وايضا عدم تطويرها
لو سمحت هل هناك حاجه لاخذ جرعه جديده من
اللقاحات
لا اعتقد اللقاحات التي اخذناها في
العضلات كافيه والذاكره المناعيه
للاصابه بالفايروس وتؤدي بالنهائي الى
الحمايه من ال ال الحالات المرضيه هذه
اللقاحات التي اعطيت في العضله لا تستطيع
ان تمنع انتشار الفيروس فقط تمنح حالا
مرضيه وامنع حاليا انتشار الفيروس هو منع
لمده شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر فقط في اخذ حقنه
جديده سوف لن يعطين شيئا ممكن يعطينا
تغطيه لمده ثلاثه اشهر وهذا جيد للناس
الذين على خطورهم
ثلاثه اشهر يعني
جيد ولكن للانسان العادي اعتقد انه
الذاكره المناعيه كثير شكرا جزيلا لك
بروفيسور علي فطوم انت خبير لقاحات
والاستاذ في جامعه
[موسيقى]
الامام المتحده في افغانستان ماركوس بوتيل
من كارثه الانسانيه في افغانستان بسبب
قيود طالبان التي فرضتها الحركه على
النساء الممثل الاممي التقى اليوم بنائب
رئيس وزراء حكومه طالبان مولاوي عبد
السلام حنفي في كابول وحتى الحركه على
التراجع عن قرارها منع المراه من التعليم
الجامعي والعمل في المنظمات الانسانيه
واثاره الامم المتحده من
الحصول على الطعام والتعليم والرعايه
الصحيه
استقبل الافغاني اول ايام السنه الجديده
بانفجار عبوه الناسفه قرب نقطه تفتيش في
محيط مطار كابول العسكري وفق ما اعلنته
حركه طالبان فدم رسول العربيه نقلا عن
مصادر مستقله ان الانفجار اسفر عن مقتل 14
شخصا واصابه العشرات بجروح
في ملابسات غامضه يستهدف انفجار منطقه
مقتضه خاضعه لنقاط التفتيش المكثفه في
كابل عاصمه بالقرب من مطار كابول البوابه
الرئيسيه لمن يريد مغادره افغانستان
مثل هذه الانفجارات التي تقع وسط الجماهير
ووسط العامه من الممكن ان تقع في مدن
متقدمه والتي تخضع لاجراءات امنيه مشدده
كامريكا وجارتنا باكستان واسباكستان
وغيرها من الدول المواطن الافغاني العادي
مغلوب على امره يامل بعد كل تحول سياسي في
البلاد ان يتحسن الوضع الامني لكن اماله
غالبا ما تتلاشى مع كل هجوم جديد
سوف تستمر نعمل قريبا
ترجح المعلومات الاوليه وحيثيات الانفجار
بمسؤوليه الداعش عن العمليه خصوصا ان
السلسله التفجيرات الاخيره تبناها التنظيم
الانفجار هذا استهدف منطقه حساسه وفي اول
يوم من العام الجديد لوجهها رساله واضحه
لسلطات في كابول بان العام الجديد سوف
يكون محذوفا بمثل هذه العمليات عبد الله
نادر العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه ثغره في انابيب
الذهب الاسود تغرق العراق في ازمه في فساد
كبيره
[موسيقى]
من جديد في العراق اعاده قضيه شبكتي تهذيب
النفط ملف مكافحه الفساد الى الواجهه فقد
بدات تتضح الصوره تدريجيا بخصوص قضيه
التهريب التي هزت البلاد وحسب معلومات
قدمها جهاز الامن العراقي تم القاء القبض
على 94 شخصا بينهم ضباط الكبار والتجار
الامن العراقي عن الكميات التي كانت تهرب
شهريا والتي تقدر بنحو 75 مليون لتر وكانت
تصل ارباح هذه الشبكات الى ما يزيد عن 250
الف دولار يوميا تقسم على افراد بها
[موسيقى]
ويتم الاعلان عن هذه التفاصيل استكمالا
للتحقيقات التي كانت قد اسفرت بدايه شهر
نوفمبر الماضي عن تفكيك اكبر من شبكه
لتهريب النفط في محافظه البصره وكانت
السلطات العراقيه قد كشفت حينها ان هذه
الشبكه التي تضم ضباط من قوات شرطه الطاقه
التي تتولى حمايه المنشات النفطيه قال
قامت باحداثي ثقوب بخطوط تصدير النفط
الخام من اجل سرقته ثم تهريب
السؤال المطروح الان كيف تتم عمليه تهريب
النفط من العراق
تحقيقات فان العمليه تتم عبر ثلاث مراحل
من خلال ضباط ومنتسبين وتكمل مهمه الضباط
في تامين الحمايه للمهربين عند سحب النفط
الخام من الانابيب فيما تكمن مهمه
المتعاونين من افراد الامن في تسهيل حركه
الصهاريج الناقله للنفط المهرب عن طريق
تقديم رشا اما مهمه المهربين فتتجلف تسليم
الاموال بعد البيع الى المسؤولين والضباط
المتورطين كلهم حسب عمله
ان عمليه التهريب كانت تتم عبره ثلاث
مراحل من خلال الضباط المتورطين والمنسق
او ما يسمى المندوب والمهربين
مهمه الضباط والمنتسبين المتورطين هي
تامين والحمايه للمهربين عند سحب النفط
الخام وكذلك تامين حركه الصهاريج
ومهمه المندوب هي اصدار البرقيات
والبوجرات الرسميه لحركه الصهاريج ويتم
اصدار البرقيات عبر دفع الاموال او تصدر
باسماء مصانع ومعامله وهميه
واما مهمه المهربين هي تسليم الاموال بعد
البيع الى المندوب الذي يسلمها الى الضباط
المتورطين وكلا حسب عمله
وفي ارتباط قضيه التهريب وتورط مسؤولين
فيها اكد رئيس المحكمه الاتحاديه العليا
اعلى سلطه القضائيه في العراق القاضي جاسم
محمد عبود الى ان الفساد الكبير في العراق
هو الذي يرتكب من قبل كبار الموظفين او من
قبل بعض الجهات السياسيه وهو الفساد الذي
يعيقه بناء الدوله
لجنه التحقيق العراقيه بما وصف بفضيحه
سرقه ضباط للنفط الخام في محافظه البصره
تكشف عن اليات وطرق عمليات التهريب وبيع
النفط المسروق قضيه النفط تورط فيها تسعه
ضباط في وزاره الداخليه
تتراوح رتبهم بين لواء رائد شاركوا شبكه
واسعه لسرقه نفط الخام في محافظه البصره
الجنوبيه جهاز الامن العراقي اطلع لجنه
التحقيق على معلومات استخباراتيه جزئيه
بشان قضيه التهريب قالت ان حلولا الليل
كان شرطا لاتمام عمليات السرقه وبشكل يومي
والدوره المنوط بالضباط يعتمد على حمايه
المهربين اثناء احداثهم ثغره بالخطوط
الناقله ثم مد انابيب منها الى اماكن
تحميل النفط عبر شاحنات تقوم بدورها
بتهريبه الى اقليم كردستان الشمالي ومنه
الى سوريا ودول اخرى حيث يتم بيعه يحصل
باطو بالمقابل على نحو
320.000$ حصيله ثغره انبوب واحد وتقدر
كميات المهربه يوميا من خمسه الى سبعه
صهاريج بسعه 50,000 لتر للخلق الواحد فيما
يقدر عدد الصهاريج المهربه من 40 الى 50
صهريجا بمعدل 75 مليون لتر شهريا اللافت
ان عمليات سرقه وبيع النفط لا تقتصر على
محافظه البصره بل ومنذ سنوات تتردد
معلومات في تقارير محليه عن عمليات سرقه
وتهريب للنفط ومشتقاته في معظم المحافظات
العراقيه التي يتوفر بها الذهب الاسود
[موسيقى]
ادى الرئيس البرازيلي الجديد لويس
البرازيل في العاصمه البرازيليه حيث يتولى
المنصب للمره الثالثه
اليسرى تفوق على منافسه
جريئه في تصويت اكتوبر الماضي
في البرازيل
[موسيقى]
الى اخبار الساعه الرياضيه زياد عبيدات
مساء الخير مساء الخير شكرا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام لحساب الجوله
التاسعه عشر من الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
لكره القدم تعادل تشيلسي بهدف لكل منهما
مع مضيفه
هذه النتيجه رافعه الى 25 نقطه في المركز
الثامن لفريق الاهداف عن فلان مقابل 4/10
في المركز الثامن عشر
وصلت وسائل الاعلام العالميه اهتمامها
بصفقه انتقال اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى الدوري السعودي ونشر صحيفه
وادي الايميل البريطانيه تقريرا عن احتفال
جماهير النصر بصدقه في الدقيقه السابع من
لقاء النصر مع الخليج ضمن منافسات الدوري
السعودي
وكتبت الصحيفه على الرغم من ان رونالدو لم
يصل بعد الى النادي لكن المشجعين النصر
ليس بامكانهم الانتظار لرؤيه بطالهم
الجديد في الملعب
وشهد متجر نادي النصر السعودي اقبالا
كبيرا للحصول على قميص رونالدو وذكر صحيفه
الاقتصاديه السعوديه ان المتجر باع اكثر
من خمسه الاف خميس يحمل الرقم 77 رونالدو
مقابله نحو 120$ بقيمه تصل الى مليونيه
ريال بعدنا هذه جميع القمصان ومن المنتظر
ان يصل رونالدو الى الريال خلال الاسبوع
الحالي لبدء مشواره مع الفريق العاصمي
المتسابق الاسباني كالو ساينز بالمرحله
الاولى من رالي ذكر المقام حاليا في
السعوديه للعام الرابع على التوالي وتصدر
ساينس المرحله التي بدات وانتهت في مخيم
البحر في ينبع بمسافه وصلت الى 630 كيلو
مترات وفي بقيه الفئات حل الارجنتينيه
مانويل اندوخار في المركز الاول في فئه
الاكواد وتصدر الامريكيه ريكي بريبيكا
الدراجات الناريه بعد معاقبه الاستراليه
دانيال ساندرز بسبب تجاوز الصراع
زكار الحقيقه من اهم الفعاليات اللي احنا
نقيمها في المملكه العربيه السعوديه زي ما
انتم الان شاهدتم بانفسكم كيف كبر العدد
المشاركين كل هالابطال وكل الفرق من انحاء
العالم تيجي عشان تحاول انها تنافس وتثبت
نفسها على ارض المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بانها قادره انها تخوض اصعب الراليات
واكبر الراليات واهم على الاطلاق وهو رالي
دكار همم السعوديه اسماء اكبر اسماء
موجوده اهم الاسماء في عالم الرياضيات
موجوده في ارض حقيقه يعني تعطيل كثير
للراليات شاهدنا اا خلال الاربع سنين
الماضيه همم مناطق جدا جميله مناطق جدا
همم
يعني همم
مخصصه للراليات في التنوع الجغرافي ما
تلقى في اي بلد ولا اي مكان الا الحمد لله
بلد مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولا تاخذ يعني كلام يعني اسال المتسابقين
كيف يشوفوا المنافسه كيف شافه والحمد لله
الترتيبات التجهيزات اللي يقدمها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في جميع همم
المناسبات فهي بشهاده الجميع لله الحمد
افضل نسخ دكار على الاطلاق
اللي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه نشوف
السنه هذه انتقلنا في مناطق جديده همم
كانت البدايه من ينبع والنهايه هتكون في
في المنطقه الشرقيه في همم فيها الخبر
الحمد لله اليوم خلصنا المرحله بسلامه
طبعا ما كانت همم
[موسيقى]
همم ما كنا محظوظين همم اليوم همم ضعنا
بعض
المناطق كانت شوي صعبه ولكن همم رجعنا في
نهايه المرحله بقوه وصار ترتيبنا السابع
اليوم هذه بدايه المرحله ان شاء الله
وبكره طبعا المراحل راح تكون اصعب
ونحاول نتقدم يوم بيوم ووو وان شاء الله
فالكم الفوز باذن الله
في انطلاقى الجوله الحاديه عشره من الدوري
المصري لكره القدم يلتقي النادي الاهلي مع
ضيفه بيراميدز على استاد القاهره الدولي
ويحتل الاهلي المركز الثاني باربع 24
بعد التعادل في اخر مباراهتين بينما يحتل
بيراميدز المركز الرابع برصيد 20 نقطه
الموسم الماضي انتقل لفريقان ثلاث مرات
حيث يتغلب الاهلي في ذهاب مسابقه الدوري
وخسر اليابان ونجح الاهلي بالفوز على
منافسه في الدوري الربع النهائي لمسابقه
كاس مصر
وهذا من الجوله التي نفسها من الدوري
المصري لكره القدم يلتقي الزمالك مع اسوان
ويتصدر الزمالك المسابقه ب 24 نقطه متقدما
بفارق الاهداف عن الاهلي وسيدخل المباراه
بمعنويات عاليه خاصه بعد الفوز على
الاسماعيلي في المرحله الماضيه اما فريق
سوان سيحتل ترتيبات الثامن باتنه عشر نقطه
وتمكن الفريق من الفوز على المصري
البورسعيدي في الجوله المانيا
[موسيقى]
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك صهيب شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا وفي بحر المنشا الاكثر
ازدحاما في العالم وعلمتني قوارب غير امنه
عبر عام 2022 اكثر من 45 مهاجرا رحله
خطيره للوصول الى السواحل البريطانيه رقم
القياسي سجلته رحله اللجوء في العالم رغم
مشاعل الحكومه البريطانيه لمكافحه الهجره
عبر المنشد الذي ابتلع ايضا ارواح المئات
في البحث عن حياه افضل
وفي البحر المتوسط كذلك تواصل القوارب
الموت محاولاتها الوصول الى اوروبا على
سواحل تونس انقذ الحرس الوطني اليوم
188 بعد غرق قواربهم من بينهم 94
جنسيه فيما احبطا الحرس سته عمليات اجتياز
للحدود البحري
وعلى ضفه الاخرى من البحر المتوسط لقيا
مهاجران مصرعهما وتم انقاذه اخرين عندما
غرق قاربهم قباله الساحل الشمالي للبنان
حيث تقوم اعداد متزايده من المهاجرين من
الرحلات
من الاقتصاد المنهار في كل من سوريا
ولبنان
المعاناه اللي هي السبب اللي خلاهم يهاجره
البلد اول شيء فقط كان الشيخ نحن عايشين
هون تحت خط الفقر للاسف شيء انا وواحد
الناس بدي ارجع وبدي اسافر انا كنت رايح
مع اخي بس انا بتامنت مع المصاري لحتى
اروح مع اخي نحن بدنا نطلع على بلاد
الاوروبي كان على المانيا هولندا وكان على
فرنسا ليش لانه هناك على الخليل هناك يعني
بيحترموا حقوق الانسان انا اذا بصح حل لي
سفره اليوم او بكره او بعد شهر او بعد
شهرين بدي اسافر
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نهايه اخبار الساعه وذكركم بابرز
العناوين
الايرانيه على حفله الانهيار والنظام يلتف
على عجزه في كبح الاحتجاجات من اعدامات
وبشر شرطه الاخلاق
برايتي
2023 يصدموا العالم بازمه ركود وشيكا
صندوق النقد الدوليه تنبؤوا بسنه صعبه على
الجيوب
واقتصاد العالم سيتلقى ايضا ضربه من الصين
بسبب كورونا واوروبا تخفق في وضع اليه
مشتركه لقيود السفر
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى على العربيه على
مواقع التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]